yes something half past eleven if you make start
thanks for coming up your what I pray you
stress micas in other rooms kath sp did
not go to everything that I put in all
competition and all people a hair okay
to speak ball
depth he buys his the plaintiff has  my
step is brings throw
yes something discount hire an eye wiktoria
is from microsoft
there with him dealing with all the fun
double declines his axel help him
to image all security there at the iron and
the there to the customer native locations already
at muslim  to the comments
part and into the pipe people dobbs
services or wishes to be known as cs ts
okay just of fresh the mind taiwan the quiz
and that who has an ampersand family there he
on such a machine and I travel is what we
min
khaman is  not fair and the security
person is our ring, it is so logical
that I am there in the real statistics to
the most companies
while on the devil supremes the word
on s' on reason house and speaking to the
security
so you can imagine how much  at an intake
of security to work with one hundred
ermelo percent and operation guys and
for the last year's who thinks that
the tick white your cutting board the devil
I looked at new wars may be at some
point
is most security i'm craft  myself
and my first goal in the cap style
start to travel and that we runners know
him in pocket and as we're going to your for
the times a day a snail okay so hope
hall and can help you to make all the
pink secure a  maloney dresses and people
a bunch in the coating de lions aquino and
ad and nothing ever drops kids the arabella
diadem options and moss while lady you
become he sees him goodbye for that you are
he started then I knew the monuments
those points village school the same into
the  processor realize what actually
sits on the cooling tank
chili already started the people and exactly
iping krishna another talco patrice
going the lever is already focus on the
tools and will and almeria list with the
pigeon on skis as lily testing
automation and it's like okay yes I'm
going  the daycare and why not
ultimate my security key basic ripped
read the pinkies
are harmed during click with myself and
kiewit security and its service
to the German and the setup okay
so I knew the focus on some more fun pink
like nam
[ __ ]  drinking tea and son
okay lets get a life frank and the special
null and wipe the cloud press the der on the
pillow is okay leads car and some
high tide week to measure and chances
security and already warm prince with you
out  how hard in one song because
online security guy take sting
basic wdd is it the chance of winning the old
girl and the security ow [ __ ] ultimate
worst app will make you clean I saw the
police and anderson will the ddr is it all
my workplace purchasing publications  in
a cloud and again would prefer in numbers
it is the cooper and ethical about the at
babs
and about a bit of cut from grace stepney
not to put some security vinckx
and that idea to control ball the patient
and off wanted sam demo school you know  well bye bye
speaks gray
so lets start find parents my patterns
would focus the other iron what at still
can be applied to the and i called like
the amazon and the google listening
to the right word got the amazon ai will
add it so I have  a
tools bind me that friend names like
that the that the prince pulsar
prepared to applause had an amazon so the
cheers frank
I have for you and the touching the cabbage is
the finches ball the this quote order and
warming and king cab all the  infrastructure
and also arrives online offered practical
advice is music and tnw is what we
implement for men that today tomorrow
the branch is subscription per a
warm fleece is what department that my
clients almost every day am at rasking
often also a workbench the images donkey
god  people around like oooh 3d white the
products one would see him since the
subscription castien af ​​in you can me
in the white to your and where people can
read all the test the in warm because
subscription the patient subscription be
just for the production
you can go  moar traveler and make it
subscription per application
it seemed to start checking the ball that
subscription per and warming
and the same principles axel goals there
man will have a lot also something something
all have the chance to land subscription
the sec is a tank so that there are also some some
iron  self permite
and walked cool is frank you will become
very old on the show and the cupboard snap henk
is iron polis is bizarre royal with
my decals to kill later what he that
jesus' light up slowly exactly you know
to be king per glass of wine until  that fold
will be resources which much sander letter
is all that there is of the rest photo d is
on 6 vintage idea prm a wheel that mast
palm and that you always ask that question with the
privacy
the private food should not be outside a
european in my  policy all all
locations
only known for you the restio at
data center source oil nori
so and the [ __ ] is what you have then who is
mans and the love subscription to the
devil on a chair the architect and
why not going to be able to the clone
resources  which charming compliant
security center business what you
pretended to be an old one on the box and the just
one step
queen their picking up in the portal
security center and the no the link and
not even you're not the security who
salt
you're going  too much like they had
a security center is anne-lie zinc
what is happening quran and this as a
hijab my sins and mediation steps
infrastructure is a buy per in it
for get and whales that fancy step
like nyx nyx finish ready because it's
not only border security at if if he
wanted consistency you get the gate and
it's all boats those guys recovery
whole with me mistake is already different
makes him strong and it's all effect
is here does the fold all your
infrastructure is cold your it  reads
protecting your cell phone from so to sneak
you my traction and the always all
rebl joling from structure and
rebuilding and meter to king between
as if all tissues are full of the security
perspective
and another advice is already surrounding
golden time a reflection okay okay
yes  then have the subscription they have the
policy is a bucket wring
arm are cronshaw productions obstruction
for the people people should not do and
check my oil in the production
subscription
ever check what you don't push that is it
belongs to the productions search about the
cia  see the piper I know I think in st
candide there what I know bnei your favor
it is a chassis that Parkland just a few
sitting arm can classify the school deck samples
in the service Gijsberta
the my prince Paul once production is
not of the gement  bank it's just for the
pipeline and idea behind a t is the label
and not that he who you are supposed to live and
is ajax 1 and then andries week gives the
customers and if they already go then letters
in matteus live at for the microsoft on
amazon the  are tanks and will erase
thumping what this word
okay lets tap again on the
concepts and lets look at the impost
report so basically lets look under the
friezes my letter first point
yes so there is something to be
chili pipeline in jesus' heart  the
security and this is where my work is
theology
the mosstime is poor spending never ice
is pocus gone securing the point
porn
securing pipeline myself and
implementing the security process in the
pipeline until i'm gone to show some hot
tools which you je  can yes implement and
when you're like i videos we that it is
rick warren what the knowledge video and
the at your go-to help you with the basic
and security i spend as the end of
the day weekend speaker late but like an
old particle  euro that live in trix and
the party color
ziggo injection with the manga again silent
solution the grain the third
would only become a
service in that the pipeline in
then the tradition in the code
okay so desirable and so to take the chance
Tapping on spar I hear him and Zuko
moment although people seem that the tank is
when applying the policy is
business what is happening started so
they are already missing something the architect Europe is
always there myself
I am with Enrico I that is with a
pitch  college one the poncho and
social ai
portal epa the goals I felt and sat in
an iron source manager that this
always goals for the policy in Jean I
am so you notice him that the
Netherlands and I chose I I
chose woman he signs his  shape in
plant shelf but in simple wine gums or
avery axel word you're doing to
the acer resources arno check the war 2
s'posing jean so
you cannot live is policies every
honk source source krups
subscriptions oh what ivio
applying this policy is  the rekkelijk to
the subscription
there is living catch if you're not alone
pink is an old-fashioned subscription and
other subscriber children are allowed is exactly the same
for that there is another check you
can blight to the management cold the
management group
yes basically the management group shovel
within those interiors, here I
never and there that you read that you
are growing your subscriptions
there is a particle per core and make it
cabinets previously I feel we thank the
production subscriptions and the time
subscriptions
you can walk in be again numerous  box is in
the management buys absolutely a cry
the management group
facts to live for the production
subscription and you can dab widely the
management group which is like for the
all vinckx the race and the skin it is
some time she then wants to charge policies
which my  god
how strict for the pigeons test
subscription system won't get people
there a site a goal beijer experiment
with beers
such a policy is michel king to offer
costs belts and you live charging oc
switch more strict until the patient
has subscription of course because of this
have the toe subscription battle with
warns on comics and a second one like
the test
dislike okay yes I have a goal is directly
all other subscriptions
you do that you don't have me on him it's
always hurt it worked and applause peace
palace is about the
management group  level and if your touch
with polis is agreed by the management group as
a subscription parent
because importer logical positions picasso
with is like a I just chose the
global the least drove the level in this
trip I will I will choke additional what
I a  applause cases also everything
brings so basically fjords folding the
new subscriptions all the time
that we love to have something put out the
post-chaise up light and maybe time such a
person like security people have so good
reader all and i want to be  sure
what being grace pixar applied in media
two to a new great this subscription
and with is what your hard formation child
to the blue print and sticking that
poperingse to the management groups
as we already suggest a bit set right
even you do he wanted  toe
subscriptions and new office namely
bal the policy is my the management group
are charging policy is to top the
management at spie cost and you're
getting better
sambal de els google the growth plates I already have
a lot for it can be better out is not
capable to  remove and
talby's what I really wanted concept
such as income the cover people all the
acer subscriptions and
drop children source is the self and
leather bracelet
king to make some mammals what the hall
we like to focus on a
tick all those who prefer the solos
and a site on the and I want to paste the
claimant on the amazon and Missis
simplified process will do that on a
scan already offers a sail along with
notes risi my arm
has simple 5 piece of for the post
explain
the security steps porch and blank  and so
shares thai boxing sw
double on such a codons wickham I count the
echoes for acceptance tests and then
ever ever fingo sidi sidi yes pipeline
shoots in
and big efficient in that the production and
the I as into the operations quite
subasic and who then the  release of pink is
home and that is something I already remember in
operation price
bad guy sting yes there would be step
what Wiedijk again just come operation
inspections and adding the security and rico
friese price
well what on the principles that lot on the
patterns with you  can apply poor nat
puccini you on play all of and
idiocy you stink and are dead tank
which my books offer like no lo
hanging out with gift european maybe
you other they have placed oh oh
yes okay may be with more time is a
night like to  play
both wii wii speak about the first
place with you who have the square or solos and
who have the springboard who on the wii
square the features ears and the duration from
the cabbage
this is where you can introduce the fun
model left basically adjust
simplifying terms of fred  modeling
arrangement valley with bread and drinks are
hocker and like okay what language economy is
nice application what old caught estimate
that the bad guy goetvinck
antje store are simple that he they
have them that is something like this
yes urethra using the exchange code weasel
studio weekly
vinken ball the security appliance and
securit extensions and download with
men who are under the market
and the where provider dealer the open
source voter of the big security
twisters and centuries in the michael
treasure so it takes just a few clicks their
stable and get understanding that you  're
trying to hang out of the van while your
liking this
will help the security appliance already you
had a mess of developing in need some
problem and there is still security
appliance I prefer it maybe more
the problem again the security appliance
is steal something responses  he looks like the
devil anyway, there is a blazing race, we
swim in style with the devil at a festival and
the second is following details is what I
can make a
box about the pull request things which
are going to check if a time when  you're
like a everyone do the cat order coming
out and my practically he indicates who
is who in America can dewey floated
this hole has yoko who interferes in the keep
up or in toilets
so basically if you then is just the sum
project  privately i were checking the
the the syntax and who do you know who
comparison with the sam coding practically
poor in the place
will who will get wet eve online to put
war the credentials in the children
story with something you can do
alt class i will help you  I revius my
sound cloud
my all time consuming that is the b-side and
that image
microsoft ass amazon a thousand look and
take I mean this is I just
mentioned security perspective it as if for
the educational perspective and old man
I will see the sea the toilet
parents mistakes but sometimes with us
about those steaks so the coming to you
can with is where I have an interview that the
city and cold and everything is running back
room tinder apple
while you're like or your coat is so there is
post or  whether me nothing landjes
in the rabozaal your running the state that
coat and everything is a landing between v I
saw there see the case is it
from my kink the city economic chair
and they live on the requirements
while building den hul looked up fishing
you that I  have that opportunity like if so
then just have the like to high line one
pink defense management labor il garde
boats last jurgen the
the walls package challenges am the
africa cup that package was just
giving to another guy wright and consciously
like implemented a go
that  is also when it is cold, the
catch is just okay, that was a grim one, it
seems to me that the stem is winning the problems
that crd is again, Krawinkel what on
the package with light breeze, that again
with deviations or someone who read-write
web and  I would be okay, I would have an increase in the
cabbage after that you
think you have many functions, I
always make sure that I have a new one
on the tools which helps you to
monitor dependency mandy management on
the acceptance, there is no infrastructure, it is
big and thick  if I want to have a
percentage risk
you will find a template you can check
elderly people who for sam security potential
auctions
security scan henk krol configuration and
scanning
security acceptance testing it is not in
use it comes for all of these principles
chance of the secure that we  ongoing
lifecycle al-sadr dropping bis in the
fancy ward apps he buys from the agenda
of cash games although a c and then again in
the macho and no
video so in the parallel mean the
configuration jacks and the pantry and
testing to which doesn't  It fits where in
the devil
I have the entire pentest cell we do
I put on the paste I have once in
two weeks and war with the AOW suggest at
one time infrastructure and at that
locations critical of you step already  to
think pentest or vinken mode in bounty
program' and there something on the little finger that you
can implement to the rational
versions but its most important remember
that the continuous montage kiki and then
in iron
you miss I saw the ezerman tortilla did
you know that I  the security center started the
security center ex-libris fred
intelligence there and article intelligence
and most important incredibly frank with
then a crazy bunch of applications that
to date like it or like no I have
a video so that the Muslim gate and then
I do it to you  Although games remained,
the blame can be read post
mortem to prepare the team of the strings
light LED finch is not to have a king
and make with post mortem think about
growing looks at what I have a lyra with and tired
tired of improvia security
zoë supply co de  basic concept so there
already had on him
I become a thin and implemented I something
taking the time it is which ladder the
times to implement my mac divers
not yet
implement Allah him I'm going to
focus on the practical wants some of
them with  your working girl I already work
you links about the food percent on the
security thinq
security mistakes so lets look for from
the concepts level
and chemists had about simplified bio on
the delivering the solution and time you
think of income diving school armpjes
using the prem
branching strategy  what we now have is
the price on theses as a large
swimming pool like from dokkum
de der subscription and clear from list
in living management role palermo relaxed
policies and he does that I do the
production and the
strips and and blew out in your enormous
management  buy for the racing with otherwise
this show subscription arm on rating
again the rail did the elderly who
and have like to give like more strict
house okay the daily life will be on was code
lionink the social looks like a bee
turn the colt and who are you busy  the net and
I already is co2 jaap bos I knew that the
devil on a branch with triggers' like
share image pipeline and I will
find it king again the gray pipeline and again
pink into them
hd subscription and evie much like that'
squirts over the  release is coming up
who had you blocking the devil on the rhine
jumping the master
and basically year repeating his voice
on the word will the expulsion
acceptance so always on then there seems to be
a production battle all
this fun that you have a lot of radical impact is
rubbed  I left and do the replacement is to or
your working with the cote leaks
management ideas extensions and a
ladder him there the open source and the
commercial because like the desk in is the already
open source they would release from the
microsoft
you know just  from base extension arm
using the exchange, the desk has
a plaster just like that, I buy the English Bible
for the exchange, all in the
exchange studio,
yes if there is open source, the bonbon
looks promising, it is possible on the fresh
of
and  check off the bible for fear the old
track is brown that can't remember what
some on the public housing everything
they are working on neck and then do
some commercial company slim where I am
in fortified bib
way to provide some extensions for the
diferente
and those thorsen ankle  thing the eclipse
will start can just a sign use my
and little fingers ball the the the prick with your
hookshot we already think on like' the basic
pink becomes your interest tab rider and
implement light led start 5 so to get
credentials king off with you're  not
putting the tendentious
okay if you're in the processes hollow be
pipelines like seo and sea the pipeline
you can do and other action chicken the
safe in order to some time said mom min
as sound okay what they do the best bread
we don't poetic  in the image pipeline
you do not take the step persons who can measure
you spread the creator ipad
pipeline the security pipeline theres no
single appeals to me was leo duym
turning is the reflexes
company culture and reflect the teams
workshop info for him i am getting better  then
something in the image pipeline and this
prevents you to do all all directions
and disco in bicycle note length that
reads Member States parallel
pipeline where do you get that you is what
I the news is the frost franc is
via divine this
as I heard about it  I'm choking with acer I'm
standing here at the full skate which
was containing candy silent can training
the powershell
and sama you a test and the of social
security test for the arryn templates
it's going to be the commission but
there some things potharst a and white
part-up article 1
isk extension africa and in the devils
pipelines and application photo that is
so basically that the extension checks
arnhem templates for the name combines
like hey you have
public label ai pini yoram template,
you often hear him say that the Netherlands is in
crap  shown on Sunday in storage heard
him that in owl it and tricks him on the
train
and missis be I gets online from the
check ingram template and girls were
poor his
infrastructure is a big as heroes
are pink what up this cupboard weather phobia
sezer polis  is here will be your doubloon
toilets exactly here I know this picks this
is the link if you're
big are a template you your basic
less illusions pipeline and julia
slowly the release with some of your
source is an at camp line this long
bounces I  trembled and shook production
policemen
this is what you can do you can write
with polished to the pipeline
in the app on sir gareth i combine the
extension with allot soul
just to reflect your positions in the
pipeline sam and jort olinka
york image i can fly the police  syntax
there in for your interstar is a colt is
going to be complied
the downside is that with tail then grab
the synchronization which means laws the
polis is with your head light in the
subscription
billion not automatically like you can
gatlin in the amp everything is is  it asks
and you think oh never, of
course if you're not interrupting the code
and pablo in day on services and if you
interrupt my I eat joke thinking ball
the sob sob is reasonable the tour a
chance to the the  panty management I check
the tape and the two track the updates to
the miracles image is his little finger
the free extension in your nose there is a wide
shot additional something big just like the
miracles image is with the live on strike
and that there is a bit on the  extensions of
the colors that are in the front five in
microsoft videos for the bite
some internal
pubic bone large insight
yes so and I am tone and the
subscriptions the all tanks are
offered that next to people but I the
policies
iron management group such as acer monitor
and the  security center security center
for big on like to your dashboard for
security
okay who is about lifecode concept
themselves and the other wit them all time
and let's go let's go big evergreen
groups in the practical
my haircut the iron and the deployment
so manga sharp the  wanted policies
basically a on the processor open source
and where you want one that happens if you
yes it is in helping sorry
never will this will be the positions everywhere
webeling that your haircut you can you can
follow me check what is a site that is on
the  polis i saw that a
it is true that you stick with one
poverty is like that because you stick the
sample my arm wet custom induce something like that
it's like and you nothing and jason gate with
this stuff that is primitive what weather now
working van den brink dedication the
parents and now the is like your
checking admire source is cries for too
long let it be that his ball is yours you do
n't do a lot of time and there is
a lot of cry it you can make the demands
either the night and the devil on
regarding  to research the girls long
he
your place or shipping get
things price of his big night because of
this policy and that guy's responsible
for that police as cream
oh marriage and app and the automatic
lelystad so that of actions
your soul I watiser just so you are  start
has the policy pings
start again this has to be done so late the break
your existing pink's
and I you then have salman
posey pain I will put a get political
in amro Hoofddorp my hairdresser the
until the compliance again plenty of the
wallabies policies and in your source
for basic not
you can just go to the time and see which
was fourties of not comply
that the best case what Sigismond compliant
so European I want you can I am sea
beach suspended is not comply with have
a save of the policy just everyone in all
this mouth or
each him inside blythe after battre
sauce get
additionally with policies and given
deeper in view or having weight or
perhaps at core
lookin site or the weather thomas giel and you
make you characterized the rules as of
the with again many perhaps black for
sample in Weesp articles Kees something
I just got some politics
okay a soul jazz goal laurent du him and
feel like a confident start your channel
already has the smalls buy them you can
start roco of the always motu the in
for small sound that is normal you
the police aim to have slim people who
previously knew much about the subscription
to the management group or you can define
the blueprint barry feature the place
basically barry channel place the setup
blew policies and maybe am
additional options which with particular
case already in the blue  print and I
myself so in way in which case,
however, your subscription shout it
and placed under bed management group
with pooping is on like'
along hear my mother identity and get and
access and the arm getting everything hangs
in this case snails are all
and there the set on the policies and you
mrs there is a subscription that can
only leave him not to offer global
from my or the e d and n roll myself to
be able to delete who so left wars
posies de goetvinck wall tissue prince
about york  rating him you bring the wire
and so you can tip my chain various
links oh yes I give you shouts the new
fashion and something people especially here
can go back to all all the group brings
okay we good luck note to the policy is on
the management ropes  and of course we
like to see the stones what is actually
got and I want to build subscriptions
and the business work your studio she walks
on the security center the good ticking ball
the security center is that you're not
supposed to be
and she is a  security expert [ __ ] when I
count you see what is especially compliant and
recently radio system like a the
observations and [ __ ] starts to win that will be
some back standard and as if I can
on the gate at the camping vacation
you should see I cuecore
would basically  i can do you can see how
to your in the grip of like me
you guys that and the already working get
additional points
so the switch works after get additional
points of your adding some security
vinckx know you will be such a big people if
one gives him a  sangha you can presenti or
management such a kepie ai laik okay who
wants HBO indispensable and to be improved about
then we start on the tanks
h&s I am a see all key pair are alike
mine also secure score
security scores are of access  there is
the word in advance white oh what security
center at source she already has on the PC quick
service and if so in clothing the
containers and finally we something I will do it
right in the period that the think if
you're the flooring emperor google  adsense
is I know log insight the security is
there like this
and I can tell you what is around there if so
in this case it will I will
wonder what is fair is had walked the
security center world has its own trike
just to this cross-beams already  the
advance functionality like what I can
do with it can implement the fun time of
the adapter application controls and bc
exactly that we have the whitelisting for those
overtoom jeans and that I have an app drawer
just-in-time access for the weather thomas
no lettuce  I have York note the weather
until maybe or label in the public
just-in-time access all of you who took I
learn you got the bird and open the
gate for the private high tea for
the limited amount of time and other more
tanks in  nutrition the cabinets free of charge so
encourage you just to have a and e public and
export
costs just started to do something that belongs
to them create
pink especially also analytical space
for the becomes space and if your reply
with an der weerd maybe string just as
long as it costs per  week or maybe
that wise for the if you're working just
in the policy thomas like mike the signal
costs you nothing
yes likers have change alcoholic
ball the in too tight support and the pink
bottom nice management at vvv start
focus on the application and cold  and the co
double up and think about the extensions
and Prince's Day the particle rick simple
on the desk a bit like so
essential Joost in his journal i.e. in
Microsoft and something open source so
specific to upline and I already
check everything Jews the security tight  eyes
with your writing the
it's not for the online yogis
it's all it's like a the project is
implemented
is I a c and typescript and nothing
home close yes o yes o
almost everything mentioning
my uncle was my ginkgo don't know
to tick offered
infrastructure is a colt is like just
wanna die samples of arnhem template of
staff in the pond on the terraform
what he might jetted extension
switch tricks
in form for the acer own than who they took
anointing offered that his juliet
I checked the status of reception  and
analytical the terraform part
what the f you if you're in for structure
is measuring in arnhem template de nek
swinko what you can do is just take the
securedrop c
extension and if you're going if you
don't like a lets lets  look is there born
to use at the on that even he would
have shot himself the marketplace
and look for the extension merger school
between cure villages
kit and basically when the roseum yo
rescue quiz it is like a your point
inc ok
visjes like the place where on like
malfunction my god enlil particle gay site your
hollyhock a level and my drap like
the deploy director i&a at life like okay
mrs barry omar a template arm and place
lets look and see I was there like that
some problems with the code and men jorah
linguist pipeline oh knew  As
particolari I test alto
check out the house to held an ask you
are the pipeline
yes so mah meter to and erase so nice the
particle there I sample is not much I
when I see thumping source what I do then
is I and then it is already running  the looks and I
can take a look at the polder once the
director walked the samba is a skier on
all the steps what what is most important
it also contains cbs paul insight into the
zip
so on your antique title of the civil
csv file with basic who you  always like
what the sex I walked there
privately on fire beer for
one of your Arnhem temple x in this case
with is like a dick sample battle the
storage show encryption in the train
is not in the mat of will not be enabled
so the  property long the or so supports
for the SGP you have all kinds of punishment there
is still place but a at the impression are
sorry yes I think rhipsalis emergency fund
and already so
point like okay who is what bizarre
private templates which ought not
for only the with  combined
while cesky self-contained sam
pre-defined
accused the compliance tanks and
if you like okay vet spine and my mom of
law so I never leave what I in the show
and diego in the in new york gropes and mac
the exclusions
in again  you know just out like okay Dante
okay
on cycles you can then you can make the
excuses yes so
bisping sat going to be north so I
rinse the pope or skip controls and you
can find like okay arm of who they
understood and jacked  it also eat something that
the action
your site is the joint again in site on
your image or in the parrel about the stench and
back the culture pitch important and about
the bed
bisping sexist so the neck think what we
like to point and game wii  shardel hank
I wish something like that you can just try and
implement
is already the wide shot extension I will
be the commercial and how it smothers you
getting you while serving what I
kind of love this or the fear tension
and game your just get free and  no blink
and denyo rescue gills pipeline
the simple home step light on
so
you can save you know the fine the
particle hear product conditions colt is
which food the few of your apple khartoum
I
and then it becomes nothing in stand i
get all to the  site white sword message
right there and if you king to succeed
soon pilot this just or so kainth
music takes 4-arm
name minute h of x then I game show
at the pool statistics it's not in tricks
all your image still continious with you
can  get
the statistic is happening via
code and the finch is like you can see
which is one on the project they break into
the Jews and
bring jeeves will something he is and what on
the already did it likes it he sat on for
your a miracle  delight price and click
nuts
get the about rio and yes so that is x there
undead and then I become a logical
licensing part because when you're
including some on the packers
these other did not match license wifi
spy and to grumble I can become and  they are
under the other license those gmail
[ __ ] are going to acquire I the open
source of your coat and I know I will
buy the commercial for you company
then you won't get int oil stream forest and
will erase slim greetings Frank
oh what the hell  and with what we as
helios' in the microsoft you will
we the already suggesting that and the in
another pink
microsoft recently started him between
the together chose to extensions about the pepe
jeans is again you're using at the same time
on my again developing  so oceans and
mary they have a microsoft security coat and
everything is something in the close video with you
know zainab it someone you that some
beanie you will erase with chance for white
0 cupboard
basically or genetically to sign up
one becomes i get another the good the  view
just like one on a bim skin with mike
open source code that
what do i get the coles and chad scan f
you get the microsoft security risk
detection and beans kim vs length and
anti malware scanner
will when you to sign up do you want bed
contacts  from the support and as a child
York in the six of those Leica
in the day observations and your channel like
you are your provider the information and was
never linked with
and jack oh you will find out what so you
can just go get it for free
and here I want to give is an A-label in the
extensions
which contains so risky a hose
the server or links ah display stables
femma in the scope so the consolation of this
run crets come with
particle hair extension lok support your
image directors and check the  another
blog give your goal such markets
dance shows
the winx kandinsky is more focus I do
fox-it to access the compiler or partly
will basically it fox about the security
like old compiler links order could
grammar and if you're using the
typescript car between just like you
stole also dishonored vinkt and natal time and
of course for the security fix haran
that the typescript and then a check mark are
anke my work and hours photo d
when an ebeling quiz something not
working on some of our guests gadgets
that  I the class guests gadgets so
so basically that is a killer whale to the legend
who hit him to defender stabled
company that just got him that I am a
scan of the fresh potential for the construction you
are you starting use men of
or album what you  can do is you in
Corsica the results in the can school or
should I have a goal is publishing all the
security on everything xbox
is an artifact ear to the sam external
place like the wind on skype someone like that
and the additionally in photoshop actions
becomes your we  like to implement based on with to
swallow all c she is a next
up
you can by is you're just taking care
front feels beach tools little fits and
everything is from my show with tools in one
to grab and
am your defining call it going  to
impact yoro image so that I can set the
commendations a-label and off and outsite
your an old jacket for the crets
just for the we the simple
potential scanning
think so I want it around the sun so on
the extensions which of my  family and it
takes a big and for ordinal adjusting
momentum in the pipeline
and if you're doing proper i like
checking
the infrastructure for checking the
credential for all our offline maybe
some custom test equal to your
application and definitely using the for
took my  error party the pendants I
check your key link the most common
security issues
because you will also be under the underworld
statistics of security statistics
with tail struggle again the basic thanks
check my bed risk in wages also
very important but oh yes definitely  will
also then night and give the twist
implemented with which it remember it
like espinal do this is from Dubbeld
just world yes I hope it is is not the
case
so I had takes I hope that the
summer trip about life coaches make some
a  cold action
for my tanks what you kind of remember
the walking dead garments and business
where you don't check the subscriptions ball
the police principle of offline policies
like let's start with the relationship
then want the security rules the business
schools and maybe some team already not
security  center is your help help
in wool top form
the microsoft infrastructure in after in
even
and pocus real focus on the cia see the
security tools on land to speak
whale in more detail like and more
complicated scenario
take a look at all the interpreters I hear you have
had questions bags just a game and
go into more details
my bread washed the chain that writes
the kind of party and tips and tools which
she I like all the duos a while if
you if you're using any color glo so that
I can use the amazon oreo  check we like to
use an amazon sorry open source stuff we
also suggest you total the securedrop chair chine
the poster of the signs square agree all
the open source tools for age of the
always like the call method
bossink into the guidelines and a
report  something basic with summarizes
the sphinx becomes the can use to protect
your a [ __ ] and your apple
chassis the pipeline
tess al cash google i home securedrop
chair train b will have the resources
if you're like us a longer to publish
free slideshow
i don't have  on the crawl and barely
to wipe along and the high some pink
which is what is champion full-time and
since my bed keeps razor running he
is completely turned out to be thanks
for being can white rocking I give
him any questions apple  i have time
l i have a full-time alt
yes
will the issue nathan that link via the
wiseguys ball toe what is not so i too
great delirium that debt switch daily newspaper
yes
okay so basically jan then with the record
[ __ ] photo of Marcel of a son
asia ambatta which means that you sticks
gay gianni die brienne maybe it's just
updated still remember
module the update oh my could it focus may
be an that manufacturer area of ​​simple
as co2 is within us
some questions or anyone knows when i okay there
is something  lifetime and aj then want to be
between lunch and here drove tanks of
can only that copy of a sam checkmarks
full
[Applause]
[Music]